it's smarter in most ways cheaper faster
better at coding multimodal in and out
and perfectly timed to steal the
spotlight from Google it's gp4 Omni I've
gone through all the benchmarks and the
release videos to give you the
highlights my first reaction was it's
more flirtatious sigh than AGI but a
notable step forward nonetheless first
things first GPT 40 meaning Omni which
is all or everywhere referencing the
different modalities it's got is Free by
making GPT 43 they are either crazy
committed to scaling up from 100 million
users to hundreds of millions of users
or they have an even smarter model
coming soon and they did hint at that of
course it could be both but it does have
to be something just giving paid users
five times more in terms of message
limits doesn't seem enough to me next
open AI branded this as GPT 4 level
intelligence although in a way I think
they slightly underplayed it so before
we get to the video demos some of which
you may have already seen let me get to
some more under the radar announcements
take text image and look at the accuracy
of the text generated from this prompt
now I know it's not perfect there aren't
two question marks on the now there's
others that you can spot like the I
being capitalized but overall I've never
seen text generated with that much
accuracy and it wasn't even in the demo
or take this other example where two
openai researchers submitted their
photos then they asked GPT 40 to design
a movie poster and they gave the
requirements in text now when you see
the first output you're going to say
well that isn't that good but then they
asked GPT 40 something fascinating it
seemed to be almost reverse psychology
because they said here is the same
poster but cleaned up the text is
crisper and the colors Bolder and more
dramatic the whole image is now improved
this is the input don't forget the final
result in terms of the accuracy of the
photos and of the text was really quite
impressive I can imagine millions of
children and adults playing about with
this functionality of course they can't
do so immediately because open AI said
this would be released in the next few
weeks as another bonus here is a video
that open AI didn't put on their YouTube
channel it mimics a demo that Google
made years ago but never followed up
with the openai employee asked GPT 40 to
call customer service and ask for
something I've skipped ahead and the
customer service in this case is another
AI but here is the conclusion could you
provide Joe's email address for me sure
it's Joe example.com
awesome all right I've just sent the
email can you check if Joe received it
we'll check right now please hold sure
thing Hey Joe could you please check
your email to see if the shipping label
and return instructions have arrived
fingers crossed yes I got the
instructions perfect Joe has received
the email they call it a proof of
concept but it is a hint toward the
agents that are coming here are five
more quick things that didn't make it to
the demo how about a replacement for
lensa submit your photo and get a
caricature of yourself or what about
text to new font you just ask for a new
style of font and it will generate one
or what about meeting transcription the
meeting in this case had four speakers
and it was transcribed or video
summaries remember this model is
multimodal in and out now it doesn't
have video out but I'll get to that in a
moment here though was a demonstration
of a 45-minute video submitted to GPC 40
and a summary of that video we also got
character consistency across both woman
and dog almost like an entire cartoon
strep if those were the quick bonuses
what about the actual intelligence and
performance of the model before I get to
official benchmarks here is a human
grade leaderboard pitting one model
against another and yes I'm also a good
gpt2 chatbot is indeed GPT 40 so it
turns out I've actually been testing the
model for days overall you can see the
preference for GPT 40 compared to all
other models in coding specifically the
difference is quite Stark I would say
even here though we're not looking at an
entirely new tier of intelligence
remember that a 100 ELO Gap is is a win
rate of around 2/3 so 1/3 of the time
gp4 turbos outputs would be preferred
that's about the same gap between GPT 4
Turbo and last year's GPT 4 a huge step
forward but not completely night and day
I think one underrated announcement was
the desktop app a live coding co-pilot
okay so I'm going to open the chbt
desktop app like miror was talking about
before okay and to give a bit of
background of what's going on so here we
have um a computer and on the screen we
have some code and then the chat gbt
voice app is on the right so chat gbt
will be able to hear me but it can't see
anything on the screen so I'm going to
highlight the code command C it and then
that will send it to chat GPT and then
I'm going to talk about the code to chat
GPT okay so I just shared some code with
you could you give me a really brief
one- sentence description of what's
going on in the code this code fetches
daily weather data for a specific
location and time period Smooths the
temperature data using a rolling average
and Ates a significant weather event on
the resulting plot and then displays the
plot with the average minimum and
maximum temperatures over the year I've
delayed long enough here are the
benchmarks I was most impressed with
Gypsy 40's performance on the math
benchmark even though it fails pretty
much all of my math prompts that is
still a stark improvement from the
original GPT 4 on the Google proof
graduate test it beats Claude 3 Opus and
remember that was the headline Benchmark
for anthropic in fact speaking of
anthropic they are somewhat challenged
by this release GPT 40 costs $5 per 1
million tokens input and $15 per 1
million tokens output as a quick aside
it also has 128k token context and an
October knowledge cut off but remember
the pricing 5 and 15 Claude 3 Opus is
1575 and remember for Claude 3 Opus on
the web you have to sign up with a
subscription but GPT 40 will be free so
for claw Opus to be beaten in its
headline Benchmark is a concern for them
in fact I think the results are clear
enough to say that gp40 is the new
smartest AI however just before you get
carried away and type on Twitter the AGI
is here there are some more mixed
benchmarks take the drop Benchmark I dug
into this Benchmark and it's about
adversarial reading comprehension
questions they're designed to really
test the reasoning capabilities of
models if you give models difficult
passages and they've got to sort through
references do some counting and other
operations how do they Fair the drop by
the way is discrete reasoning over the
content of paragraphs it does slightly
better than the original GPT 4 but
slightly worse than llama 3400b and as
they note llama 3400b is still training
so it's just about the new smartist
model by a hairs breath however we're
not done yet it's better at translation
than Gemini models quick caveat there
Gemini 2 might be announced tomorrow and
that could regain the lead then there
are the vision understanding evaluations
it was a real step forward on the mm muu
as you can see a clear 10 points better
than Claude Opus again I'm curious if
Google Gemini can exceed it though the
improvements to the tokenizer could be
revolutionary for non-english speakers
the dramatically fewer tokens needed for
languages like Gujarati Hindi Arabic and
more don't just mean that conversations
are cheaper they're also quicker and
what about multilingual performance well
this time they didn't compare it to
other models but compared it to the
original GPT 4 definitely a step up
across languages but English is still by
far the most suited language indeed here
is a video of some of the models
mistakes ending with some dodgy language
tuition I know enough Mandarin to say it
wasn't perfect at churing let's root
root root for the home
what was
that sorry guys I got carried
away right for
round
Francisco I have feeling I'm very wrong
hello uh my name is NCH I'm here with my
coworker hi I'm sh I'm trying to teach
my coworker how to speaking manding we
want to start from simple words like
niow can you teach him how to pronounce
that of course hey Nao nice to meet you
KNE how is pretty straightforward to
pronounce it sounds like KN how just
make sure to keep the KNE part high and
then go down and pitch on the how give
it a try me how
that was great really good first try not
you you're natural it really wasn't he
needs to work on his tones and her face
was the giveaway there were a lot of
other interesting video demonstrations
but before them the GPT 40 blog post
from Sam opman put out tonight he made
the argument that putting this capable
AI tool in the hands of everyone for
free is justifying that open part of
open AI less about open weights or open
source more about open to to everyone
without ads or anything like that he
also draws our attention to the latency
of the models in many ways that is the
key Innovation with GPT 40 by dialing
down the latency you dial up the realism
as he said it feels like AI from the
movies getting to human level response
times and expressiveness turns out to be
a big change indeed I think I should get
a little credit for predicting her like
AI in a video from a month ago but now I
want to get to those demos the response
times were amazing and the model was
clearly designed to be flirtatious note
that in Senate testimony last year
samman said we try to design systems
that do not maximize for engagement so
let me know in the comments whether you
think these demos are designed to
maximize engagement okay so this is what
I wrote down what do you
see a I see I love chat chpt that's so
sweet of
you yeah well I really appreciate all
the
help so yeah as we can see
um wow that's quite the outfit you've
got on yeah as we can see you know we
can chat in real time I was impressed
though that it could speed up its
talking on demand of course one two
three hey actually that's um that's a
little slow could you count
faster Sure Thing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
okay that was a little bit too fast of
course open AI must be given credit
because for blind people this could be
revolutionary right now the Royal
Standard flag is flying above Buckingham
Palace which is the signal that the
Monarch is present how exciting to be
there while the king is home try and
tell me exactly what they're doing right
now please um right now the Ducks are
gently gliding across the water it will
also help you with interview prep by
analyzing your appearance how about you
I'm awesome list listen I got some huge
news oh do tell I'm allers well in a few
minutes I'm going to be interviewing at
open aai have you heard of them open AI
huh sounds Vaguely
Familiar kidding of course that's
incredible Rocky what kind of interview
well it's for a software engineering
role but I just need to know do I look
presentable
professional well
Rocky you definitely have the I've been
coding all night look down which could
actually work in your favor maybe just
run a hand through your hair or lean
into the Mad genis SP Your Enthusiasm is
what's really going to shine through I
don't have a lot of time so I'm just
going to throw this on what do you
think oh Rocky that's quite a statement
piece I I mean you you'll definitely
stand out though maybe not in the way
you're hoping for an interview okay I
got it I got it I could definitely see
GPT 40 being used for mathematics
tutoring here is a 30second clip but
notice also the slight glitchiness at
certain moments relative to angle Alpha
all right so I'm pretty sure this is the
angle Alpha right here
right cor correct now looking at the
triangle which side do you think is a
hypotonus
um remember the hyot I'm not totally
sure I think I think it might be this
one but I really am not sure this side
AC you're close I also noticed quite a
few glitches in the demo sounds cutting
in and out the one feature though the
open AI wants you to really focus on is
the video in capacity you can live
stream video straight to the Transformer
architecture behind GPT 40 and so the
video in functionality is certainly
impressive note though that the reaction
time of GPC 40 isn't quite as immediate
as for audio Greg Brockman the
co-founder of open aai has to prompt it
to react to the Intruder overall stylish
feel they might be getting ready for a
conversation or a presentation given
their direct engagement with the
camera sounds like we're in for an
intriguing interaction I'm curious about
the lighting you mentioned could you
describe it a bit more is it natural
light are we talking unique fixtures or
colors that add to the
atmosphere the lighting here seems to be
a mix of natural and artificial there's
a noticeable bright light overhead
probably a fixture casting a focused
beam downwards which creates a spotlight
effect this adds a dramatic and modern
feel to the scene the rest of the room
is lit more softly possibly by natural
light filtering anything did anything
unusual happen
recently Yes actually uh just as you
asked another person came into view
behind the first person they playfully
made bunny ears behind the first
person's head and then quickly left the
frame it added a light-hearted and
unexpected moment to the scene now the
focus is back on the original person
with the leather jacket nevertheless gbt
40 can produce multiple voices that can
sing almost in harmony
and really try to harmonize
here San Francisco San Francisco in the
month of May but maybe make it more
dramatic and make the soprano
higher San Francisco in the month of May
San franisco in the month of May it's a
Friday C may we are harmonizing are
Harmon great thank you and I suspect
this real time translation could soon be
coming too Siri later for us so every
time I say something in English can you
repeat it back in Spanish and every time
he says something in Spanish can you
repeat it back in English sure I can do
that let's get this translation train
rolling um hey how's it been going have
you been up to anything interesting
recently
hey I've been good just a bit busy here
preparing for an event next week why do
I say that because Bloomberg reported
two days ago that apple is nearing a
deal with open AI to put chat GPT on
iPhone and in case you're wondering
about GPT 4.5 or even five samman said
we'll have more stuff to share soon and
Mira murati in the official presentation
said that would be soon updating us on
progress on the next big thing whether
that's empty hype or real you can decide
no word of course about openai
co-founder ilas Sask although he was
listed as a contributor under additional
leadership overall I think this model
will be massively more popular even if
it isn't massively more intelligent you
can prompt the model now with text and
images in the open AI playground all the
links will be in the description note
also that all the demos you saw were in
real time at 1X speed that I think was a
nod to Google's botch demo of course
let's see tomorrow what Google replies
with to those who think that GPT 40 is a
huge dry towards AGI I would Point them
to the somewhat mixed results on the
reasoning benchmarks expect GPT 40 to
still suffer from a massive amount of
hallucinations to those though who think
that GPT 40 will change nothing I would
say this look at what chat GPT did to
the popularity of the underlying GPT
series it being a free and chatty model
brought a 100 million people into
testing AI GPT 40 being the smartest
model currently available and free on
the web and multimodal I think could
unlock AI for hundreds of millions more
people but of course only time will tell
if you want to analyze the announcement
even more do join me on the AI insiders
Discord via patreon we have live meetups
around the world and professional best
practice sharing so let me know what you
think and as always have a wonderful day